I also want to thank the organizers of
Europe pythons and the volunteers this
is my first year of Python it has been
awesome so far and I really hope you are
all enjoying it too I am very excited to
talk about how thinking in Python made
me a better software engineer and this
is a subject I really like like the
subject of thinking in a programming
language and I really hope I can
interest you too so my name is Johnny
Jude and this is my real name
I work yeah I work at toggle networks I
design software and algorithms and
Python is my favorite programming
language but I usually use it for
prototyping my team is responsible for
C++ code for the most part and that's
what I've been doing in the past decade
so I'm going to use C++ as the contrast
for Python in some parts of this talk I
this talk is divided into three parts
I will first go over some psychological
concepts and then I'll try to show how
it relates to the development process
and I'm going to attending about an
experiment I did and its results so
first couple of psychological concepts
and I really hope you can keep this in
mind throughout the talk because I'm
going to refer to them imagine you were
sitting in a pub drinking wine with a
friend and out of the blue your friend
asks you not to think about the pink
elephant ironically you will think about
the pink elephant a few times in the
next few minutes and this is called the
ironic process Theory try not to think
about something makes thinking about it
more likely next is the magical number 7
as Wikipedia described it is often
interpreted to argue that the number of
object an average human can hold in
memory is seven give or take - there is
nothing we can do about it we can
however keep that space available for
when it is needed the most because
anything that occupies your working
memory reduces your ability to think
this is an example of priming by reading
capital of France Paris should pop up in
your mind
I almost said Paris there priming is a
technique whereby exposure to one
stimulus influences a response to a
subsequent stimulus without conscious
guidance or intention so basically what
it means that things that happen
influence your mind as well consciously
or subconsciously and it can be helpful
at some times but very much like the
pink elephant sometimes you may not want
it but you cannot prevent it think most
software engineers if not all will agree
with me that task switching reduces
their ability their productivity time
and psychology research shows that
switching between tasks of different
types like reading and writing for
examples costs more in terms of
productivity and can cost almost half of
the subject productivity time and last
is fluency which is the ability to do an
activity with little or no effort at all
so people for example are fluent in
walking so if you compare a working
meeting and a sitting meeting both you
take the same time and conscious effort
so those are the thing I'm going to
refer to throughout the talk now let's
see how it relates to the development
process with some examples let's start
by getting immediate feedback from the
code you write and this is rare in
development I got the habit of using
idle boxes called editor and interpreter
when I started coding Python
professionally that was about 2005 there
was no IDE back then and that was what
the team used and will program I didn't
use mouse and window but it looked
something like that you evaluate and
check each expression you write as you
write it getting immediate feedback from
the code you write
you find bugs earlier you learn faster
and you have confidence in the code by
letting the computer executed in its
head and not in your head so in this
example we have a short function and it
aims to find the biggest files in a
folder and this system function returns
the standard output we use we call it we
use it to call disk usage and split line
will return us a Python list of lines we
then split each line by tab to get a
sizing name pairs and then an largest
will give us the enlarges pairs
descending by size we drop the size
return the file names it seems simple
but there is a bug here and it's silly
bug and my point is it doesn't matter
how senior you are sometimes you will
write silly code so let's use the
interpreter alongside writing this code
and see how it works first we define an
example argument and then we execute a
statement and we try to sample the
result once we see it is OK we move on
to the next statement and here we can
see that the numbers are actually
strings and not numbers what does it
mean to enlarges if we manage to miss it
we will it would be glaringly obvious in
the next statement that 96 is not bigger
than 912 so we can fix it without
task-switching and with the same
information in a working memory and move
on and the benefits are that you learn
faster human and not only humans tend to
learn faster and achieve higher degrees
of expertise when they get feedback the
sooner the better
catching bugs earlier reduces task
switching and it is important here to
note that task switching is not Windows
switching so when you write code you
need to consider how it will be executed
and I do not consider actually execute
in it in another window as a different
task or a different state of mind
writing it blindly however and then
finding the bug in the unit test forces
us to task switch into a debugging mode
and remember this can cause half of your
productivity time and with immediate
feedback you also gain confidence that
your code works by executing it at least
once successfully without spending extra
conscious effort another example of
confidence when you learn si you don't
see loops and you learn not to get an
index out of range this is a must-have
skill for SI developers because an index
out of range math might cause
segmentation fault and then you will
need to debug it which is painful hard
to do and hard to forget so you will
spend years double and triple-checking
every edge case of every loop you will
ever write until you're fluent and si
loops if ever executing it all in your
head and despite all this effort you
will still have an index out of range
bug once in a while okay standard
standards of business object
representation is often underestimated
can you tell me how old Brad Pitt is you
should be able to find the answer
quickly because you should be fluent in
reading such data structure if we want
the list of string optimized for
filtering items matching a regular
expression we can use a line separated
text just like most Linux tools do and
then we can use any Linux tool or
regular expression library for
high-performance matching but it is not
easy to read at least is and you don't
get to wonder who is Numa Thurman my
point is regardless to the
implementation of your data structure
keep a standard representation for the
user which is often yourself then you
can actually visualize it in your mind
and think about it effortlessly so I'll
take it a step forward what if we wanted
a dictionary with keys that
research of all by regular expressions
in this case we can use the line
separated text for the keys and those
keys may be longer so we can use the
offset of the key in the text as a
dictionary key it saves space and it
saves CPU and hashing but it looks like
that can you tell me now if Mia Wallace
is alive or dead how about now again
regardless to the implementation of your
data structure you need to keep a
standard representation for the user in
gdb wendy when debugging C++ code we
have modern Python scripts that allow us
to pretty print the C++ standard library
data structures and the problem is
usually when you write your own
structure if I write a structure like
this it would look like that in Python
we have a wrapper but in Python as well
I often see user implemented object
without a wrapper or a non-standard one
and remember if you say I will write
wrapper later it won't get done it
usually won't get done and if you don't
use standards it is more confusing than
helpful so if you can read it you can
visualize it in your mind and you can
think about it effortlessly discuss it
with other developers and you will find
it easier to work with and less of a
distraction from your main task for me
it's more important than the plain
readability it's the ability to
visualize and think of the data
structure effortlessly standard API is
also important and a very good example
for standard API is the counter you can
really to mmediately and be alone but
the number of Walking Dead and the
counter uses a very well-known data
structure with very well-known API and
the counter also also tells you
explicitly what it is the only
difference is the constructor using a
familiar data structure an API is the
base of keeping your mind free to
think about many other things one thing
about the magical number seven is that
it can hold entities of a limitless
amount of entropy so it is harder to
remember nine random random digits than
two random words which in terms of
entropy holds more information and in
the same way it is more it is easier to
remember a counter which is a dictionary
with a different constructor than
counter which have no explicit reference
to a data structure or an API speaking
about dictionaries if I tell you that I
want to store something in a dictionary
it keeps you mind free and allows you to
give undivided attention to the
explanation that follows but if I say to
you that I want to store something in a
map well if you are a C++ developer you
will start wondering about things like
why do we need the keys order or why not
use a hash map or why is there no good
hash machine hash map implementation in
the standard C++ library and even if you
don't think about it consciously your
mind will prepare itself for answering
such questions now compatibility and
another silly example here I've function
who returns the list that contains a
string of a number for a number in
sorted numbers if the number is valid
and Python here allows me to explicitly
describe it and it also dictates how it
may sound in the voice inside of my head
or in a talk in front of an audience
C++ without diving into details does not
allow composition of standard standard
library iterators and algorithms and in
some cases it forces the user to create
new copies and in other cases it forces
the user to use to modify data in place
so it may look something like that
and for me it looks like a regular
recipe if you think about a recipe and
an actual recipe like this one you have
mixed ingredients in a ball period pour
the ball content into a mould period and
bake them all along with its content
period and those were three sentences
with intermediate variable and a lot of
useless obvious information a baker
reading it may just translate it in
vying to bake the mixed ingredients
because that is all they need to keep in
mind so this example show the functional
composition and it works for well for me
because I like to think functionally but
Python allows you to be consistent and
write imperative ly or object oriented
if you want you can say I want this list
sorted and contain only valid string F
ID numbers and in the recipes case you
can just say mix and bake and by the way
this is a like C++ because actual C++
looks like this which is a topic for a
different discussion I think but my
point is this it is easier to think with
composable tools and generally Python
tools and modules in the rich standard
library are consistent and composable
and my favorite example is the unit test
mock library which is recent written for
the unit test framework but works with
any test framework
simple is better than complicated I skip
the complex part and you'll see why soon
in C++ when you define a function you
can pass parameter by reference by value
by raw pointer and recently by our value
and smart pointers you have short
pointer for shared ownership and unique
pointer for your new unique ownership
this is something you don't have any
Python and fight on everything is shared
object or like shared object so if you
have a project and you don't you don't
care about the micro performance it's
written in C++
you may think why not just use your
pointers everywhere it's easier and as
you know simple is better than complex
so you tell everyone in your team from
now on we're going to use only shared
object everywhere and then somebody
decide that they want to use a unique
pointer why because of the C++ core
guidelines it's a four hundred and fifty
page guide that any good C++ engineer
follows and now we have a problem what
if we want a function that receives a
smart pointer but we don't care which in
this case the six of the score
guidelines have an advice and it tells
us to use raw pointer and make it Const
which means immutable in that scope so
you can put the concealer before the
type declaration it makes the object
immutable you can put it after it makes
the pointer immutable and you can make
both and then you read code me see the
Const in the middle and the simplest a
score guidelines actually have a section
about it it says don't do that it work
it does something but please don't do
that
and and then you remember that complex
is not that bad
complex is better than complicated so we
decide to throw away the C++ core
guideline and just use shared objects
everywhere and then you spend the week
debugging a segmentation fault remember
the hard to do thing because of a line
like that pass a shirred pointer by
reference which doesn't make sense in C
this is not funny this is like the
culture of the C++ II every time we read
code write code or do anything with code
we just want to optimize everything in
the most absurd and unnecessary way and
we also care about parameter passing so
we can use shared pointers everywhere
but we cannot stop thinking about pink
elephants and every other option in the
C++ language and here python makes it
easier to think about other things by
offering just one one option yeah I
wanted to mention type-ins
not that part that got me laughing
though I till I got to the 2039 part
yes so now we're in the 2019 and
type-checking static type checking made
a huge comeback in the Python community
so I had to try it and it took me like
five minutes to ask myself do we really
want to define types and structure
before understanding the problem and the
solution and Python here reminded me
that it is possible to do it separately
so I wrote code and added hints later
and then I realized something else that
I didn't notice before type checking and
describing processes are completely
different tasks which uses completely
different systems and required tension
two completely different details so when
we are writing in a statically typed
language we are constantly task
switching between coding and type
defining and it's actually worst for
worse for statically typed languages
because just by define an integer it
raises the question of how many bits
would like this integer to have and it's
important because what happens when you
are wrong or you can say let's just use
an integer it's the default we don't
need to think about it we will deal with
it later so you can say we don't need to
think about it but can you actually do
it okay this is the last example for
today and it is a topic I'm very
familiar with it puts everything
together because prototyping is actually
a way of thinking a prototype is a model
built to test the concept and to be
learned from you write it once gaining
experience in both understanding the
problem and a solution and this is a
solution you're trying and if you are
satisfied with the result you write it
again with less thing to worry about an
attention to finer details writing it
again after it is organized in your mind
will make sure it is more readable
and by solving all the subproblems
before you have less thing to think
about and then you will have a little
bit more space in your mind to think
about future tasks and maintainability
and maybe find a bug or two you had no
capacity of noticing before but it does
cost you a little bit more time so
prototyping should be a little bit
faster and coding anything the second
time should be about twice as fast for
me it takes about 25% time 25% more time
but this will eventually be profitable
for the entire team's productivity
because it will reduce the complexities
of future tasks now this is this is true
for any programming language but as I
mentioned before some things you can
only do in Python in Python you can use
a dictionary without considering its
implementation implementation sorry you
can define a function without caring
about the arguments types or bits you
can think in the language you write and
not work hard to translate your thoughts
and if your production code is in Python
you can handle the type checker later
separately so along with many other
things that have nothing to do with
thinking developing in Python is about
four times faster than developing in C++
so prototyping should be at least four
times faster and there is an empirical
study here a reference downstairs and it
shows it shows an example in one domain
how it's actually faster it is an
icehole empirical research that I like
and this is so counterintuitive I often
forget it when I when I am busy working
I have a task to implement something in
C++ by adding another task of
prototyping before I write a C++ code I
save the overall time I need to spend to
finish the implement
so my question is how much of this
speed-up do we get from thinking faster
and not from fancy features and other
technical qualities that makes
development in Python faster as you all
may be aware and that got us the it gets
us to the last part I want to tell you a
story about a personal experiment that I
did and it is not a valid research not
even close but it is something that you
can try if you have free time and for me
demonstrated the power of thinking in
Python so in the beginning of this year
we were interviewing candidates at my
workplace and we gave them a well known
problem with a well known solution find
the shortest path in a text maze on the
left you can see an example input and on
the right you can see an example
expected output and what we wanted was
to understand the difference in work
times it takes to solve this in Python
compared to C++ so I implemented it a
few times in that order and I measure
the time and as you can clearly see it
takes much more time to do it in C++ and
I remember that empirical research that
I talked about before and it actually
correlated source lines of code to work
hours so I counted the sauce lines of
code and I found no reasonable
correlation so I actually had to read
the code and see what what's what's
going on and what bothered me most was
the last two implementations so as you
can see I chose the question and I
consider possible solution before even
writing the first implementation so by
the time I got to the fourth
implementation I was really bored I knew
what I was doing I knew what pitfalls to
avoid I didn't use an interpreter I
didn't have compilation error everything
worked perfectly well and both of the
solution looks very much
the same in fact both versions had
exactly the same algorithm data
structures functions and even names and
the only difference was the number of
characters so if it wasn't boring so far
I retyped the solution and reduced the
time it took me to write it in C++ and
it still took me twice the time so this
is one example function from the
implementation and as you can see I
didn't use any fancy Python feature I
did use a generator I think from habit
but I didn't use its true power it's
composability so I just populated the
set and you have to understand the time
significantly more fluent in C++ so I
should be doing the C++ implementation
faster and yet it took me twice the time
and the question is why why did it take
so long and finding failing to find a
solution that relates to the development
process the question literally became
what was I thinking about and these are
possible answers that could fit a thirty
minutes talk but we're not done yet
one more thing it is fun to experiment
and you don't need to go out of your way
to do it so in this case I just needed
to understand what process will the
candidates go through and after the
first to implementation didn't make
sense to me I had to implement it again
and see what happens if I implement it
again in Python for some reason I did it
again in Python and then I needed to see
what's going on with the C++ version and
so I was not performing a supervisor
experiment I was just following my mood
and got very interesting results so
maybe you two sometimes choose different
approaches for me sometimes I think like
something takes me it should take me 10
minutes of work I don't need an
interpreter or I want to use an
interpreter even though it's 10 minutes
so I don't need to change what I want to
do I just need to measure and with time
I will get enough samples
to hopefully answer the question of
which process works best for me okay so
whatever I've been talking so far I've
been talking about immediate feedback
and its importance for acquiring fluency
reducing task switching and improving
confidence and in Python it is just as
easy as moving from the usual blind
writing mode into an interpreter in C++
I learned how to remove dependencies on
work and work on isolated chunks of code
so I can execute the code almost
immediately as often as I would like I
also make sure to have a standard and
composable representation in API in
every project I am involved in this
helps the entire team understand each
other's data structures and helps them
even to debug each other's code also
Python here taught me the importance of
good architecture and API design because
this is it's one thing to read a book
about it
and another actually using a very good
example daily for a while I can say the
same thing about composability keeping a
consistent and composable structures
objects and models help you become more
fluent in the framework you're working
faster and it also keeps your mind free
of things that becomes obvious and
prototyping Python even if you write
language in other languages to prototype
properly you actually need to think
without destruction and it doesn't
usually work very well with with most
other languages and if you write Python
code try writing it instead of instead
of refactoring it it works for me maybe
it will work for you just as well okay
so let's see if I want you to take
anything from this talk is I hope you
will start thinking about the way you
work think about the waiting try to
think in Python
know it sounds insane for me sometimes I
actually think about some solution or
something and I can just write it in the
same way I thought of it and don't just
think experiment it's fun so please let
me know what you think it doesn't matter
if you're a junior or a senior if you
write only in Python or in many other
language languages if you agree with me
or you don't agree with me I would very
much like to hear what you have to say
you have a link for the slide here I
have a thanks section for people who
helped me write it and some inspiration
and references that you can see and that
that's it thank you very very much for
coming and for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
site will talk we have approximately one
minute for questions for Johnny yes let
me walk to you thanks for a nice talk
one small question about immediate
feedback is there a particular reason
for not doing it in tests like unit
tests instead of switching to the Ruppel
why would you want to write the same
code twice when you write the unit tests
you actually think differently once you
have written finished within it once you
have finished written the function as
short as it will be and my example
actually demonstrated it when you write
the unit test you need to switch to a
different more than think about what
will I do when I unit as the function
the function doesn't even return the
size of the files so you need to think
about how to test it and if you find a
problem with it you actually need to
switch to a debug mode and think about
how am I going to debug this function
now and you're in a completely different
context and think about conferring
completely different things that you
will need to come back to later I hope
it hands it answers your question
you can experiment and then then copy to
your code if you want that works just as
well thank you very much unfortunately
we run out of time for questions but
journeys available afterwards for more
questions thank you